hundred friends on Facebook he carries
himself in a man that has been a DC you
know so five that's called the the
ching-chong Wow paintball ancient talk
now let's go for Hans can thank you guys
is gonna be here the next on skin let me
hear fallen is one of my favorite cities
and
[Music]
like the cold facts they got nice flags
in loving here in Washington I'm
actually from a little town called
Seattle thank you cobalt II love Seattle
it rains a lot there which is one of my
favorite things because I love being
able to like us on my window I feel like
why should I try with the days I'm
you're trying let's see how great
progressive town which is great for me
because I biologically male but my
police identified me as a [ __ ] it's
important to be progressive nowadays
because I especially when you're
grinding guys
a lot of bicyclists they identify his
automobiles very scary I used to date a
woman she was really into yoga and no
sex I was like do you breathe deeper God
make up your mind the wacky situation I
actually got caught cheating which was a
very stressful time for me emotionally
but I don't think I could have gone past
without the help of my two girlfriends I
recommend that if you are in a
relationship just in case from outside
the old box I don't know a joke about
the Seahawks
besides these friendly my name is Hans
damn that's our real name thank you my
parents take me Hans because they didn't
want kids at school to make fun of me
for having an Asian name so maybe a
German one is safe
the right for the radar idealization
element and elementary school and
trainees from a province in china called
south korea so next is japan province
you know it's weird having a name like
Hans because when I go to Starbucks they
expect this game youtubers to show up so
I started using a fake name you know I
started going by the name ching chong
meet up with her I come from a lot of
big balls
why don't you say my name what are you a
geek on
I am a funny name but I think it's even
funnier that tanner is a white person
seen another one
it should be like is my Mexican friend
Ana
that's a black French a Mrs America I
love this country of ours I don't
understand all the stains in America
they stink prison don't drop the soap
not even helpful in my opinion it should
be don't pick up the soap I think it
drops myself as you want depending over
denture it may be don't drop the soap
you're so looking at rates your just
happens prisoners you know I don't
understand the Confederate flag for the
Confederate flag
it was like that time we're going to
that huge argument I try to divorce you
grab that side kind of reminisce Who I
am as a person you don't make sense I am
NOT like my agent or a living agent
because whenever someone is racist to me
I'm like oh you've a respectful people
who a lot of people make fun durations
which hurts my feelings a penny WTF
other other liberal motivations because
we eat dogs which I understand can be
very shocking because in America dr. T
like the other members but in Asia we
treat our family members
[Applause]
Asia instead of buying an animal we love
grandma unless you love being Asian
people make fun of us because we're
small p9 which it's not even true that
even for us it's not like we hear that
like oh we got small things okay we're
gonna do Bobby so well that you guys
we're going to just give up okay mister
study because that's what we do we've
learned that easily sewing machine it's
on gee Asia that are sexy okay I'm
trying to spread this around okay
because I thought these asian women are
sexy but I think you were gonna created
me [ __ ] I'm a crucial part of the sexy
process please I'll kind of skip the
good sex with me our children will be
very beautiful
[Music]
so I am single I get to be my soul mate
sings like a loser I think I do better
like this one lady she was like did you
know that because any bigger baby might
be trying
3d picture like actually does incorrect
your room is a 3d printer vagina is the
Train it's nothing a really good 3d
printer we prints one thing with lots of
areas and the whole time beautiful they
have the most beautiful centage any of
the device definitely the top ten I
don't think I could ever have sex with
fellas by dudes is only over good I'd
gotten a beautiful woman and been like
wow that woman is gorgeous but is there
a version of her that's bigger and
hairier that's less kindness I would
like to say that I I feel like mental
breakdown in some ways because I'm
feeling a deep breath you like
so much protein creatine dependency this
baby's like 27 pounds very good check
out this biceps of all those beans the
first trimester I think it's amazing
that we can make a human out of their
body LGBT brothers are brothers and
sisters Rosen systems are deserve our
respect the [ __ ] I'm talking to this one
dude who is not that respectful and he
was like dude can you imagine BJ that
means most of the gender that you're
attracted to wouldn't even be attractive
to back and I was like wow there's some
different those others I'm not home I
understand people who say yeah Adam and
Eve Adam and Steve
because Adam and Eve were not even a
good couple typically first of all this
is a big guy and the inner fruit they
weren't supposed to eat which is kind of
a man this is a big bucket the reason I
came an equal and came murder table what
we take a parenting advice so people who
raised a record they're only three other
people on the earth
we killed a quarter of the world's
population
[Music]
the hardest bosses I believe for a
girlfriend who is not only beautiful but
also intellectually stimulated by the
mental exercise of fighting attracted
the woman goes into puzzles oh wait [ __ ]
you're wearing that tonight
okay maybe do the same things I do love
the ladies I looking at that I try not
to in public because that's against a
lot it was very difficult for me though
because to me a woman is like a
beautiful sunset with race
and outside call the cops
[Music]
and I think it's awesome that you know
men and women were dating we're out here
or doing it the money sex like I had sex
like upgrade but I come back because I
had to pretend like I was a person I
wasn't to get laid so what's the point
of that like my character got a good
like very nice I don't understand like
some bad police and said it's not my
boss my natural programming like my body
sees a pretty girl
my body's like I'm sweating profusely
sure that you can get wet to start
stuttering shorty thanks a lot body I am
family you know my sister's back from a
mission trip if you don't know what a
mission trip it is that's what
whether they're all countries to get new
profile victories over legs
my sister has that what would Jesus do
bracelet or sandwich what would you soon
which is ridiculous because they never
see her behave like a Jewish carpenter
well the burnell's
do something in Asia at all we were a
Christian in her house as Asian people
which is kind of weird because the
people read the Bible didn't even see
that know that Asians existed they could
even drop us a line an Asian switched up
on the fireworks for the credit be nice
now back to the Jews my patrons yeah you
about the Jews
whole things about it I am eating this
now because I've got a kindergarten at
that in the internet connection I think
it would be stressful 7 ideology they
can be destroyed a lot of people think
that I am gay and I think it's great
that we have abortion it which is
awesome you know this is a joke and
don't make me okay I've been telling
this very progressive because that each
other
I believe in abortion I think it should
probably be people free and available to
anyone who needs it because if you only
think abortion for rich people got a
plan you're only going to work the best
babies do something to make bad parents
let's take the word for it I am a
liberal snowflake thank you very much
rednecks also got a little red bags
because you can't be a liberal all the
time i insult someone you got a cavity
in a redneck it does be like you are bad
but not because you chew that make sure
you're operating it shows me that I just
have a go important race and sexual
orientation I think it's all people I
love rednecks because they can survive
in any wilderness situation that
then exact a situation where everyone
has equal rights you go Memphis swamp
and alligator like a cul-de-sac with a
minority smiley not racist of course on
my minority how can I be I don't need to
see race I always smell it I am NOT a
racist but I didn't have like a moment
of racism like also complain and I saw
dude reading a book in Arabic and I'm
freaking out but then I thought all the
corner of the page
close his book it was like oh there's my
future plans
[Music]
saved by the power literature these
things again not a racist
I love the Black Panther movie that
movie was a great movie easily black
showrooming hero they can look up to and
not just someone like Martin Luther King
jr. now they have a big person that
dresses they attack they made it under
straws were they going to come out with
a yellow Panther huh love the cinema
yeah I understand deception all on TV
because we do not see the NSA Finch and
to suspect women you can't get on CBS a
[ __ ] poop I think we're gonna deserve
more protection I mean is if I'm walking
down the street and someone's like you
dropped your stuff [ __ ] very offended
but it's almost like you're talking [ __ ]
like what I consider a gangster you can
also give up television and show press
and I
they won't which i think is ineffective
but keep doing it because if you show me
what going devil paints these lights
will turn off so that they had to
silence but if you show me what they
were wearing
oh there's holes the nipple should be I
can metric off of that as it goes
scientifically it does not work I love
the Austrians I love the award ceremony
they have like the best director
category which I never understood
because I I've never go to watch a movie
in their life Wow look at this direction
I sure did what he was told to do
nothing didn't come up with that on his
own they have best male the best bait
female lead they separate I think my
gender which I understand like hell
America where you think you're real
actors but have you tried that with the
pair of balls well a different art form
we didn't do category without the liars
are the balls
they have snowboarding separated by
gender which doesn't make any sense to
they all look like
jackets this bottle of China I came home
high one day my male haunts right here I
am so ready
it was like oh I was just crying are you
crying I was like oh I just gotta fight
with my girlfriend was like I'm sorry to
tell you kid just earnest [ __ ]
I got [ __ ] outside what's easier
should have been a drug heaven thank my
emotions I knew some of my mom New York
City pal you know you could be arrogant
there you can be never get anywhere
of the subway I love hopping the
turnstiles and sneaking onto the subway
I think that's an awesome crime because
that's like robbing a bank
who provides with a getaway driver okay
I will escape the scene of the crime
I hate it when all those people that
could change on the train so when that
happens of what I usually do is a change
I switch cars go to the next car that
way I can say no to him over and over
it's two cars in front of him to do his
whole life before he gets a good buzz I
don't understand why in New York City
there's security on 9/11 as if it's the
date that's a problem and our foreign
policy of the country a little horny I
like the idea of a terrace looking at
the calendar
I'm very importantly active I don't
understand being America great again
because that means that we don't like
what we have now so we want to go back
to the past but go back to the past
we're just like I don't like I love all
you know I think I'm a white prophet is
agree I am a Jew probably like ten
people a lite-brite but a lot of people
will be doing it correctly okay there
are always like the Nazis so they could
put our flag and everything building a
castle or the other wing
let us be white say the Jews of the I
can do that too well I love stand-up
comedy but some clubs or shops a painter
than painting a picture and a canvas be
like blue draw something Asian a lot of
races of my experience must recover
races they don't even realize that they
are I was walking across the street the
sky comes up screams like Tokyo which
will be under set up I was like dude you
are so racist that's the light look like
this and then speak your ching chong
language
don't be racist and the post office is
right there
how much do you think bed bugs were at
the invention of the bed I was gonna
make both of their species
oh my God look mystery for God's sakes
I'm so lucky you got flanked are
mosquitoes
carpooling but I don't like it when I'm
alone which is a lot of the time people
I ever like the carpool lane is like
society I hate it I hate about me yeah
why don't you do that the longer they
watch people with friends wizzy by I
[Music]
think a parking ticket so I call to
which your wipers on my car one keep an
open line of communication with
something never said anything nice very
very kind to conspiracy theories you
know let people know that the juice got
the pyramids but they should not that
the food pyramid was built by food juice
[Music]
juice classic the twist on an old
classic all right I think it's awesome
that I'm dating a lot of people they
like to call me
premature ejaculator maybe sure - I
can't read at the perfect time what I
felt amazing
it's a cherry please yourself
I love their comedy I live in my car
actually in my van so that I can sue
coffee full time so if you didn't think
I was funny I'm sorry I'm trying buddy
hard key performance right now I know
there's someone back there like yeah
this is funny but not living there being
funny gonna bring that joke and a
partner buddy I love that man the reason
I do it is so that I don't have to do
anything that I don't want to do except
to do that part I would wake up in the
middle of winter and be like I wonder
what the temperature outside is like
like probably exactly the same as the
temperature inside as far I could just
see that on my body it does make it
difficult to date as a band dweller
because we jump to that a stationary so
even if the day goes well and I bring
her home with me we use in the balcony
is we go for a drive that's all I can
work with the car
45 minutes ago you guys aren't gonna
believe this but I hate crowds
crossing my visa everything next two
individuals one-two punch oh there's
another funny one guys there's a sign in
my neighborhood that says 20 miles per
hour when children are present but what
if the children were dwelling in the
past I love living in my neighborhood
you know I when I used to live with my
mom I used to walk my dog around a lot
and I saw people up behaviorally streams
eat or dogs think this one person he
wants my daughter like
[Music]
[Music]
struggle
[Music]
[Applause]